SPEAKER: If you run your
services on GKE or anywhere,
really, you need to have a
way to get some basic signals
about service health.
At a minimum, you want to
collect the golden signals
for your service.
Traffic is a measure
of how much demand
the service is responding to,
usually measured in requests
or queries per second.
Saturation is a measure of how
much of the available capacity
the service is using.
Errors, or error
rate, should tell you
the fraction of requests
you're able to serve correctly
or incorrectly.
And latency is a measure
of how quickly you
are able to serve your users.
You can read more about golden
signals in the "Monitoring
Distributed Systems"
chapter of the SRE book.
We'll link to that below.
Of course, you need a way
to counter this information
for your services.
My name is [? Uri. ?] I'm
an SRE at Google Cloud,
and today, I'm going to show you
how to instrument your Python
services to emit metrics like
these with OpenTelemetry,
an open source
observability library.
Welcome back to
Engineering for Liability.
We'll start with
walking through the code
to instrument your application.
Then we'll have a look
at how to query and use
those metrics in
Cloud Monitoring.
Our example service
is written in Python
using the Flask framework.
It receives web requests
and does some processing
before responding.
So we'd like to track the
request rate, error rate,
and the distribution of
the processing latency.
As always, we'll link
to the full code sample,
but here's how you can add
metric instrumentation to it.
First, we set up the
exporter to send metric data
to the OpenTelemetry collector.
It's a dedicated
component we'll use
to collect telemetry and forward
it onto Cloud Monitoring,
and we'll cover it in more
detail in our next episode.
Next, we define the meter
provider, including information
about our service we'll be able
to use to query our metrics.
Next, we define
our actual metrics.
We'll use incrementing
counters to track
requests and errors and a
histogram to track latency.
Finally, we use these
metrics to record our data.
We increment the counters on
request in the error and record
latency before returning.
And now, we have metrics to
represent the major signals
of application health--
request an error account
and a latency distribution.
Now that our application
is instrumented,
let's deploy it and have
a look at the metrics.
Our application is
written in Python
and instrumented
with OpenTelemetry.
We use this Docker file to
build a container image.
We use this YAML file to deploy
our image to a GKE cluster.
And here are the three replicas.
Next, we create this
YAML file and use it
to deploy the
OpenTelemetry collector.
And here it is running
in the same name
space as our application.
Finally, we have some
pods generating traffic
against our service.
Let's go to Metrics
Explorer and first look
for our total request metric.
We'll group it by service ID.
This shows the request
rate by [INAUDIBLE]..
We can do the same for
the failed request metric.
We can even have Cloud
Monitoring calculate
a ratio of the two for
us to easily measure
error rate for our application.
Finally, let's also
graph request latency.
Because this is a histogram
metric, we can use a heat map.
This will automatically
calculate the average and tail
latencies for our service.
So that's how you can deploy
a service instrumented
with OpenTelemetry to
GKE and view its health
metrics in Cloud Monitoring.
Thanks so much for
watching today.
We learned how to use
OpenTelemetry to instrument
our service to admit basic
signals of application health,
like traffic and
latency metrics,
and how to query them
in Cloud Monitoring.
I hope this helps you to keep
your applications reliable
and your users happy.
Don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out
on more Engineering for
Reliability with Google Cloud.
See you soon.